now surely you were saying you were in
your previous life a dance teacher have
you knocked that on the head now no yeah
you will very soon t DS for you really
quickly but now Will Ferrell you have a
love of Dance I know now if you're
surely volunteer to show you a couple of
simple moves well I mean yes of course
detail she doesn't believe in my
abilities yes you want it what could you
so I'm gonna be very quick I could show
you a Cucaracha okay you know you're
playing hero the music right yes yes
yeah because that's a rumba okay so
remember is a sensual dance it's
invincible bar we're doing a Cucaracha
or rumba which is abut the dance we're
going to do is the Rumba I'm totally
lost to get too excited down in another
religion okay how about if you could
just go side replace close if you could
just do that from the side replace close
I'm the only one
[Applause]
but whatever I do side replace today
[Applause]
so no matter what I do you're gonna do
that my left arm is acting up you ready
a mouse Diana can you keep that rhythm
crudo problem doesn't matter what I do
oh I just keep doing
[Music]
[Applause]
never too early for a 10-4 Shirley
beautiful
[Applause]
[Music]